car
最初に皆さん一つだけお願いがあります
私が行き価値はと言いましたら右手を大きく上げてスポーツなんと避けてください
いいですかいきましょういいですね
雪社長スポーツスター
ありがとうございます
私が生まれた小樽は
年間およそ6メートルもの雪ができます
毎日毎日雪かきをしなければ生活することができません
そしてをタレは坂の多い町です
本当に打つ歌詞しないと生活が華麗なんです
この坂の上にも落とし揚げが住んでるんです
をたのは高齢化が進み
お年寄りが1人対雪かきできない
そんな世界が増えてきているんです
この写真見てください
屋根から落ちた雪がパラジェルを直撃しました
皆さん雪の重さって弔うかわかりますか
ん
およそ1立方メートルで
屋根に積もった癖であれば
500キロ以上あるといわれています
こんな雪が頭の上に落ちてきたとなります
雪に埋まってしまったよっ
もしくはやぬ雪を下ろそうとして滑落したい
そんな事故が年々増えていってるんです
そんな
状況になっているお年寄り
一人で雪かきしてると誰も観ていません
本当に違いますん
その状況を何とかしたいますー月で考えていました
しかし
雪かきんでっ
朝早いし
さみしいっ
疲れしっ
とやりたくないんですよね本当は
ですから子ども行う1着大嫌いですん
ギリギリまで寝ています
その方です
でもなんとか
してあげだろう
そういう気持ちがね際ずっと考えました
そして調べきますん
スポーツの力で除雪問題を解決
これは
じゃ2年前
日本スポーツ gomi 拾いだよねー
マージ柄代表に私がでありません
彼は
ゴミ拾いルールを定めて街をきれいに入っ
そんな確保していたんですよ
私はそれに強化しました
3広いだろうよって言ってもなかなか人は集まりません
でも拾ったゴミの量で競い合うよっ
言ったの皆さんかしてくれるんですねー
喜んでご披露しているんです
なるほど逆転の発想なって私は思いました
ん
逆転の発想ってええええ
ピンチをチャンスに変えリオ
ポジティブに考え
そして
相手にん
そうかその手があったかあっ
思わせること
私はそう思ってい
じゃあ雪かきでん
この後広いスポーツ目標いく
同じことができない
一書をみんなで楽しむできないん
そう思い
は見つかった教頭
日本スポーツ18連盟
誠実じゃないか
ということで合意しますん
そのスポーツ一家議員実は3つの狂気金使っているんです
ん
一番左
およそ600キロの雪の塊を
スノー乾くにダルすポップ日本
スコップで雪を区立そしてスローカートで10m た com
その
タイムを競い合うん今日
そして右側
今度は制限時間1時間の間に
行けたとか何個作れるか
そしての重しだ
そして当職これを競い合う
この2つの合計ポイントでスポーツ雪かきという競技を作りますん
しかし
私も本当の目的はボランティアの雪かき
これを増やすことになります
ですから真ん中の
ボランティアで除雪をするというこの教
本当には関係ないんですけども
これに参加しなければ
失格でアクションです
私は
この
金池大チャンスみたいっ
こういったはずぞそれをパスポーチ一体生かしたということになります
この日大勢マスコミの方が訪れてくれました
寒いなく
そして大勢の人にこのことを伝えてくれました
ん
この現状を伝えてくれました
それによってもっともっと行き隠してくれる人が増えればいいな
そう思って活動しています
実はどう
スポーツひっかくには
もう一つ弱点卵巣があります
私たち小樽市民や
雪国に住む準備にとって1ってほんとやってを逃してくらい
もう朝起会浜
反対に穴持ってるぞ
混ぜ仕掛けを
そういう気持ちになっちゃいます
でも
雪が降らない地域から来た
愛国人の観光客今蛍の町の各
配分ですね
みんな街中で雪玉くっつきあったりとか
診察用があるダイビングしたりとか
そんなことでキャーキャーいいから彼を知ってるんですね
小樽の
堺町通二
ホームや様の人何年美濃屋社長という肩書きます
酢飯ほど私に言うんです
いやもうすぐ3
熱っとありがたいねぇ
言わ財産だねっていうんですねー
ほんとこんなにねならね独裁行き
そう理想もこの分
私は外国人遊んで臼歯とっ
あっ思いません
私たちにとってはじゃっ買い物抜きであっても彼た彼らからしてみたら
あっ他にも行きなんですね
そのときっ
私はこれも漢方しで使えないと思いました
金池をチャンスに変え
しかもビジネス車すいません
をたるみが今年間700万人以上の観光客が来ている
でもみんな
札幌にと買ってるんですね
ですから小樽は運河の周りをちょっと歩くだけ
こんなちょっと難しくいないんですん
みんなすぐ帰っちゃうんですそこへ行っちゃうん
私からごとに生にお金が落ちません
じゃあ
スポーツ雪かき用
私が体験プログラムとして
小樽に定着させて
王者リーとかおっともっと大タグを楽しんでもらっ
近くしてほしいそう思って活動しています
持っ
スポーツの力ってすごいんですん
スポーツの明るさとか
達成感
また化けないぞっていう気持ちですね
この地から本当にすごいですいいキャッキャッと思いますじゃあもっとこれをよいしょ
思いましたん
そして枝廣にもスポーツしちゃいました
スポーツへラジオ4 a
日本語どうか皆さん
こうライブが進みそして後継者問題
1卓そっか悩んでるんです
重労働なんです
その10ロードも
いっぱい参加者は増えて行ってもらう
スポーツは力ができるんです
私はスポーツと脳最強これをもっともっと広めたいと思っているんです
実は昨日
スポーツ動画に行ってきますん
約2時間
大人30人国民が国
南女収穫したと思います
hiro じゃないんですよ飛んだんですよ
ほとんずこと
5トン収穫できたんですね時間ないっ
すごいんですスポーツの力って言っ
でも私のアイディア
簡単に実現できるものではありません
ウォーカーしてくれる人がになってれば実現しないです
例えばスポーツ雪かき
小樽商工会議所青年部の皆さん
彼らが実施してくれました
そして大勢な広いも
公開大学国際文化学部の皆さん
そしてに吃音の皆さんが実施してくれました
ん
いき調停が大田区の子なりの隣の街なんですね
まっさんが夢になった洋一所の隣にあります
桜もだった工藤だとか
そういった豊富番号作物がいっぱい捕れる持ちなんですね
そして私の検便からいきますと
アイディアもん
5人
それにねやってみるの言ってプレスが言うと
実現に向けて大きく前進します
そしてその後人が
周りの人を街コンってくれるんですね
表館の中本部今後広がっていくんです
ですか皆さんアイデアがあった5人
を集めてください
やろうよって人誤認やせん
そうすると多く実現に向けて動き出します
最後に
私からのメッセージです
例えばこの仲良いん
活動を始めたけどもなかなか人って集まらない
で悩んでいきっ
もしくは
アイディアを実現しようと思っても
等やっていいかわからない人
ちょっとねドンズバになってる感じの人っていますよね
まず
自分のアイディアという棒を思い浮かべてみてください
いいですか
そして
それが実現した姿というものを追いかけてください
その時皆さんの頭の中にはみんなが笑顔で動いてる姿が見えていると思います
自分のアイデアが実現しません
それは私はプラス思考の妄想と言っています
それって頭の中だからできるんじゃない
そう思っているかもしれません
駄文
プラス思考の妄想に吹かものじゃないん
みんな強化してくれるんだろう実例と言うんだ
そう父を持つことっ
そして本田に直面した某逆洗搬送されるが何かあっ
そう思う
スポーツひっかけだっ
スライことを想いや出すようじゃなくて
こうすれば楽しくできるはずだという逆転の発想です
そして日々を
くら寿司奉納そう
これによって乾燥しました
キーワードは
みんなで楽しくなんです
これから
大学を卒業して
社会に出てい
大学生の皆さん
おそらく大きな困難が待ち受けていると思います
しかしできるんだ
みんな投下してないんだ
自重しましょう
プラス思考のもうそっ
そしてこんなにうちらだったら視点を変えてっ
そして違った方向から考えましょう平櫛
弱点の像
ほど2つあれば必ず
乗り越えられます
冒険2
混乱はつきものです
人生をキャスものです
一度きりの人生
楽しくぺーしようじゃありませんぞ
ありがとうございましたーーー